if you're like me you finished the
latest season of gen V and we're like a
lot is happening that's right Emma in
fact so much happened this season I
decided to put a little video on the top
unanswered questions to explore the
whole truth just don't tell Tech knite
and I won't stop searching until I
found the whole truth from mysterious
trackers the future of gulin and what
exactly did Adam borke and Ashley do in
the bathroom at the Pediatric cancer
fundraiser and for those of you who have
seen my detailed breakdowns some of this
might be a rehash so I've left
timestamps below so you can see all the
topics I'll be covering but before we
begin make sure to like And subscribe
I'll be covering every episode of The
Boys season 4 yeah sure whatever in
episode five Marie finds out that gulan
has implanted some sort of tracker into
her body something she has no
recollection of which could mean Kate
and her mind wiping Powers had something
to do with this in episode 7 we learned
from Dean Shetty that gulan is merely a
front to study soups so having these
trackers on students makes sense but we
never find out if these are here to
merely keep tabs on the students or
whether or not they can transfer other
Vital Information we also don't know if
every student has one of these or just
to select few Marie will sense one in
Jordan but we never see her take it out
in the final episode we saw Kate's arm
explode her hands have been a crucial
weapon in her powers of pushing others
to her will so it's kind of ironic it
gets blown off but now that she's off
her head the question then becomes could
she potentially use her powers without
her hands I think we've only scratched
the surface on how far her powers can go
now will she get a new arm I see three
possible scenarios one she walks around
with a stub forever two vot springs for
her to have some sort of robotic arm and
three she regrows it back remember in
season two of The Boys vot was
performing tons of experiments on a soup
named gecko who could regrow body parts
maybe they've developed a way to
synthesize his powers and help other
soups grow back Parts as well I also
want to talk about Emma turning Sam's
mind empty something that allows him to
commit the killing of Innocence without
his moral conscience getting in the way
how long do these pushing Powers last
like is Rufus still hitting his dick
with a baseball bat every hour the end
of season 1 had this huge twist that
homelander and VA framed Marie Jordan
Andre and Emma and made Sam and Kate the
new guardians of good Dolan homelander
is the deao leader of VA and as such has
the power to control the narrative to
his will over the past few seasons of
the boys we've seen him become
increasingly radicalized towards soup
Supremacy so it makes sense he'd align
himself with two soups who want to take
down humans but how did he know which
soups to bring to his side and which
ones to frame remember that homelander
has super hearing and sight so it's
possible he watched the whole events at
gulan including Marie's conversation
with Kate to see how things would play
out only when it looked like Kate and
Sam were done for does he swoop in and
change the narrative to his own liking
it's possible homelander is amassing a
team of soups with Pro soup sentiment
and using va's immense pull and
resources in this endeavor this is why
we see him smile at the end of the
episode everything is going according to
plan now very little is known about the
status of homelanders trial at the end
of season 3 of the boys homelander
straight up murdered a man for throwing
a can of Turbo Rush at his son
the extent of information about the
trial comes mainly from two brief news
flashes the first in episode one where
homelander lawyer says he stood his
ground the second in episode two stating
that homelander is on trial showrunner
Eric kpy states that season 1 of gen V
will tie into season 4 of the boys so
expect more of the homelander trial to
continue in episode 7 we learned that
homelanders jury will consist of human
jurors so I could totally see him get
getting convicted and blaming this
conviction on racist anti-p sentiment
thereby in his mind making the
conviction invalid I don't see
homelander going to jail anytime soon if
I had to guess where Murray and the
others are at the end of the season it
would be VA Tower or at least some sort
of VA facility all of them wear VA
hospital gowns like those at train and
polarity wore while recovering at the
tower you'd think these four kids
accused of murdering at least 12 people
would be in the most confined soup proof
cells imaginable but in instead they
look to be receiving top-notch care
access to smoothies and Andre even
appears to have his phone Mar and the
Gang did save Ashley Barrett so it's
possible she made some sort of deal with
homelander to keep them at the tower
until something can be done with them
regardless none of them except for Marie
seem to be too concerned at their
current predicament suggesting the
others know what's up after getting her
heartbroken we see that Emma has shrunk
but how could she do this without
purging it's possible it could be from
the crying itself but I like the idea
that Emma's Powers actually center
around how she feels about herself at
this moment she feels pathetically small
and thus she is small when she is
confident and strong she can get big
from a narrative perspective this seems
a lot more interesting and it solves the
problem of Emma having to purge every
time she wants to use her power a huge
unanswered question this season is the
status of the virus which we last Saw
being handed over to vice presidential
candidate Victoria Newman as far as we
know the virus in its current form is
only transmissible via bodily fluid and
can only last but a few days at ambient
temperature I don't think that Victoria
plans on destroying it it's too valuable
of a trump card should homelander or any
other soups attempt to attack her or her
family nor do I think she plans on
continuing cardo's work considering she
and her daughter are both soups we know
Victoria and homelander have had a
checkered pass so this virus is what
gives Victoria some leverage against him
at the end of the season we see Billy
butcher arrive at the woods it's quite
Poss possible that Grace mallerie after
hearing about it and the virus from Dean
Shetty sent Billy to investigate either
he or someone from the boys was who she
talked to on the phone I wonder if he'll
find Andy's body the one who died from
the virus regardless this whole thing is
proof that VA and gulkan were
experimenting on students and no doubt
something the boys will want to look
into a huge unanswered question this
season is the whereabouts of Marie's
sister Annabeth it seems everyone knows
where she is except for Marie in fact
Marie whole motivation to get into the
seven is tied around her need to prove
to her sister that she's not a monster
but a hero all we really know is that
Annabeth was taken into foster care
after Marie killed their parents Ashley
says she can get Marie in touch with her
so she is very likely alive Haley Miller
said they contacted her but she wanted
nothing to do with Marie something Dean
Shetty says is likely a lie to get Marie
flustered before her big interview and I
would not be surprised if Annabeth has
powers if Marie's parents gave her
compound V then why not her sister too
this has the potential to completely
shake up the show and I'm here for it
speaking of Marie I think we've only
reached the tip of the iceberg when it
comes to how far her powers can go Dr
cardosa claimed that Marie might be one
of the most powerful soups out there in
episode 8 alone we learn she can give
people heart attacks pop off body parts
like Victoria Newman and manipulate the
blood of nearby corpses turning them
into daggers imagine she could give
multiple people heart attacks destroy a
person with a single pop to the head or
what if she could manipulate blood
itself and heal others Tu soup Su could
definitely use some healing are polarity
and Andre polarity suffers from neural
micro tears a result of years of using
his powers and it seems the same will
happen to Andre the more he continues to
use his power it looks as though Andre
will have to choose between following in
his Father's Footsteps and it gradually
killing himself or a life of not being a
soup but knowing the show they'll find a
way to heal heal or reverse this ailment
I go into greater detail in my season 1
ending video but I think it's pretty
much confirmed that social media Jeff
was working for Ashley Barrett and VA
we'll see Ashley's assistant also Ashley
yes that's her real character name try
to get in contact with Jeff after he
informed her his cover might be blown
unfortunately for Jeff that's not the
only thing of his that will get blown I
do think season 2 will continue at
kulkan not because of any particular
plot point but from a purely production
standpoint this show is expensive and
they've spent so much money on dozens of
elaborate sets which would all go to
waste should the show move away from
gulkan if you look at the boys they're
still using tons of sets that were built
all the way in season 1 also the whole
premise of the show is soup set college
so expect a way to get these kids back
to gulkan there's really only one adult
character in the genv universe with the
background and experience to tackle the
job and that's polarity he's a soup
himself a gulkan trustee a vault Yes Man
and with him expected did not to use his
powers a more administrative job may be
just what he needs this also keeps
polarity in the picture and more
interactions between him and Andre in
the finale Ashley Barrett came to gulen
in the hopes of rejuvenating its image
by selecting one of its students to join
the seven they never make a decision on
who this person is and honestly all the
other choices Beyond beree Jordan Emma
and Andre like Maverick feel kind of
lackluster this person would also likely
have to join the main cast of the boys
so I think this decision will be put on
hold for the time being I'd have to
imagine that Dean Shetty and Victoria
Newman knew each other as Marie's
mysterious benefactor Victoria would
have had some PLL at the University and
what better person than the dean herself
Shetty would also have been aligned
politically with Victoria seeing her as
this anti-p head of the fbsa candidate
she could get along with of course not
knowing that Victoria is in fact a soup
herself whether or not Victoria knew
about the woods prior to Marie telling
her remains unknown in episode one
Golden Boy has the these sort of
dreamlike hallucinations of his brother
Sam but Sam here is a boy this is never
really explained but it could be assumed
that Kate wiped his memory of his
brother so many times that what remains
is a younger version of him and I know I
know everyone is wondering what happened
to rufus's Dick quite possibly the
biggest mystery of all honestly it's
probably just a healing power
considering the next day he's out
partying at a keger he also tells Marie
it's not what it looks like what did he
mean by that and why would he be naked
in a robe after having just used his
powers to rofy her into his room get it
his name is Rufus normally I don't
finish on dicks while that sounded weird
but we've come to the end of the video
what unanswered questions and theories
do you still have let me know in the
comments below thanks for watching be
sure to like And subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram @ thinkstory YT until next
time remember Daddy loves you very
much